When the sexual revolution began in the 1960s,
there was a standard understanding of what
should happen: ‘sexual liberation’ would
mean that people would be freed to have more
of the sort of sex they really liked, that
is, with more partners and with less embarrassment.
But what was overlooked is that this kind
of sexual liberation might, along the way,
create its own restrictions, taboos and, so
to speak, varieties of imprisonment. The people
targeted would not be those who wanted to
have more sex but those who – for a variety
of reasons – either didn’t want to, or
weren’t able to, have the amount of sex
now strongly deemed so-called ‘normal’.
Sexual liberation, while driven by a desire
to free us of moralistic judgement, ended
up – quite unwittingly – putting us in
a new kind of straightjacket, insisting not
that we have no sex, as moralists of old had
thundered, but that we feel wholly at ease
around the prospect of making love frequently
and diversely. It now became as shameful to
admit that one wasn’t having sex as it had
once been shameful to say, outside of marriage,
that one was. Stigma continued, shame too,
they just changed their targets. At the heart
of this newly stigmatised group, there was
a figure of particular mockery and opprobrium:
the belated virgin, someone who has by accident
or design reached their 20s and still not
yet been to bed with anyone. This shame has
nothing to do with statistics. Surveys estimate
that as many as 15% of the population between
20 and 25 remain virgins. The point isn’t
how many virgins there are – there are clearly
many – but rather the extent to which they
have been made to feel wretched and inadequate.
The goal of true sexual liberation, the sort
we should all be interested in, is not to
shift stigma around, it is to remove all stigma
around all consensual sexual choices. True
liberation means liberating us not just to
have sex a lot, with different partners, in
ecstatic clinches, but also to not have sex
or to have sex quite late on or, for that
matter, to have bad or inept or clumsy sex
– and never to feel bad on this account.
True sexual liberation should liberate us
not just to be athletic and tantric and polyecstatic
– but also to be weird, reclusive, interestingly
shy, intelligently embarrassed and about as
peculiar as we want to be – and still retain
the right to honour and like ourselves.
What we should aim for is to build a society
where we finally stop suffering so intensely
around our sexuality, even if that sexuality
means we don’t want to, or haven’t yet
managed to, have sex. That, and only that,
will mean true liberation.
Did you know that The School Of LIfe is  actually a place?
10 places in fact; campus' all over the world from Melbourne to London, Taipei to Istanbul.
With classes and books and much more...